欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,这一节课我们来讲一个非常常见的案例
而且在我们很多的店铺中都会有遇到过这种情况
也就是产品询盘非常多,贴母也很多
但是呢,它的订单非常少
甚至来了几百个询盘,一个订单都成交不了
这种爆品,我们要怎么样去优化
为什么这种产品一定要重视呢
因为你这些产品会带来很多询盘
那么业务要去回复询盘,占用很多的时间
但是这些询盘的质量, 以及它的转化效果都是非常差的
那么会占用很多公司的资源
老板对这个板块也是非常重视的
而且也不希望来那么多询盘
对我们的成交一点促进作用都没有
但是呢,对于运营来说
就感觉好不容易才来了一个爆品
放弃了,实在是太可惜了
那么这种产品我们怎么样去优化呢
那么下面我们来讲具体的方法
如果你的产品符合下面的这些维度
可以按照标准的去优化
我们来看具体的问题
第一个,这个爆款产品
我们首先要去判断
它的关键词和人群是否匹配
比如说我们要去看它的关键词
看看这些词经不经准
如果不经准的话
那么大概率也会导致你的寻盘的质量非常差
第二种情况就是
你的这个爆品可能都是你在推广
所以说它一般来说点击量都是很高的
在自动车方面都是很高的
一定要去看点击的词是哪些
比如说有一项商机
或者是说它的人群标签是否有一项商机
有寻盘带来的
如果这些板块
它的效果带来的都是非常好的
但是呢
它的寻盘的质量非常差
那么我们也要针对这些人群标签
点击的高点击的词进行优化
因为这些标签带来的寻盘
所以才会导致寻盘的质量差
所以说反而是对这些高点击的这些标签进行优化
那么具体的优化方法呢
如果是自然流量的话
我们就不用改
如果是直动车流量的话
你的流量词高点击的
即使它带来寻盘也一律要屏蔽
因为它带来的寻盘的质量太差了
第二个就是我们可以选择关键词推广
因为选择关键词推广
我们可以自由的选择更加精准的关键词
以及可以排除掉之前那些高点击
转化的悬盘差的那些关键词
第二种情况呢
就是对于一些有高点击且有寻盘
但是寻盘来源的国家不准
以及寻盘来的质量很差
我们就要对这些国家标签
人群标签对应的高点击的标签
或者是来寻盘很多的标签
进行一个价格的调整
进行一个测试就可以了
第二种情况就是
你的产品的款式跟访客国家不匹配的时候
那么你这个爆款产品来的寻盘
通常来说质量都是非常差的
首先我们要分析它的款式和国家的准确性
比如说你要去参考一下市场热销款和目标国家偏好的款式
特别是这个目标国家偏好的款式
这个款式如果跟你们的差距很大的话
好 比如说你美国市场跟非洲市场
你的款式是更偏向于非洲市场的
那么这个时候就会有非常多的非洲的流量
美国的流量就会非常的少
但是呢你们本身这个产品A就是做美国的
来了很多非洲的
所以说这个款式一定要选对美国的偏好的款式
才是最佳的
你要去查看这些国家的精准度
是否符合我们的产品市场销售
比如说你之前的这款产品已经数据非常好了
那么你就按照我刚才说的款式的偏好去看一下
是否符合你们目标市场
这个国家的偏好就可以了
优化的方法的话
我们通过直动车去改变了它标签
比如说之前这个爆款产品都是非洲来的巡盘
非洲点击的嘛
我们想要美国的銀盘跟美国的点击
那么这个时候我们通过直动车去推广这个爆品
把点击量积累在国家美国上面
持续的积累一段时间
就有可能把我们爆款的产品的一个国家的标签扭转
那么后期系统给我们推荐的流量就会更加的精准
第二个就是我们要考虑更换与国家相符
且与目标国家相符的产品主图或者是产品相应页
比如说你这个是A爆款
那都是来自非洲的是吧
这个非洲编号的
那么B这款产品跟A这款产品是相似的
或者是说同样标题都可以描述A产品或B产品
但是B产品更倾向于美国这个国家的风格款式
那么这个时候我们就把A这个爆款产品的主图换成B产品的主图
以及在详情页里面做一定的调整
调整成为B这款产品
当然这个方法容易会导致你流量下降的
所以说这个方法谨慎使用
除非你已经被逼到没办法
或者是说老板跟业务反感太严重
那么这个时候我们才会考虑换款式
三个就是价格起定量运费详情页
这些都会影响到你的目标人群的转化
因为不同的国家他偏好的价格起定量运费和详情页
他能够接受的程度都是不一样的
那么这个时候我们要去分析一下同行爆款产品的价格起定量
尽量的参考他们的价格去针对性的优化
开始的时候我们不建议是采用低价去引入
因为你前期可能这个爆款因为你用了太低的价格去引流
导致很多人就是因为你价格低起定量低才来找你寻价的
所以说就会显示你寻盘很多
但实际上只要你把真实的价格起定量跟客户聊天
那么他就直接就不回复这种情况
所以你的价格我建议尽量的跟你的实际的价格相差不大
也就是可以比实际的低一点点
但是不要低的太离谱
这样才能够吸引到更加精准的买家
这样的质量寻盘更加好一点
这里这个板块一定要注意点
如果是你做RTS的话按照实际的价格折扣优惠
这些作为一定的营销来吸引一下你的真正的目标客户
第四个板块呢就是业务的话数还有客户的反馈
比如说业务反馈说寻盘很差那到底怎么样差法要给出一个标准或者是说你要列出他差的一个数据或者是指标啊比如说你为什么差寻盘不回复的问题吗
或者是说回复了你自己聊天发的话数或者是说跟人聊的牛头不对马嘴这是不是也是业务话数的问题
另外一种可能新注册的买家太多L0的太多这也是一种情况
第四种情况可能就是来的国家的寻盘都不是我们想要的国家的寻盘
所以说这也是导致你寻盘质量差这些都是会导致订单量少的原因
所以如果订单少不单单是寻盘质量差的问题也有可能是业务话数的问题
或者是说他本身对这个产品的迫切需求的问题
比如说有些产品是季节性的现在不是当下最需求的时候
那么这个时候可能许蛮多但是成交定量少这是正常的
但是过了某段时间现在是这款产品最好的销售季节
如果是还不成交的话这个可能就是我们引流的时候把这些不精准的流量引进来导致的
一定要去多分析从运营维度和业务维度同时去分析就可以了
比如说我们在后台看一下业务聊天的内容
我们去看一下他聊天到底是不是很精准或者是说他聊天的方法是不是比较正确
这个时候我们跟业务经理老板等等这些直属的领导去沟通一下
反馈一下寻盘质量问题
沟通一下业务的需求以及重新定位一下我们说的优质寻盘是按照什么标准去判断的
我们一定要有一个相对清晰的一个判断标准或者是一个描述
如果你连标准跟描述都没有只是一句话说寻盘差那这种方式很难让你持续的去改进
一定要把框架跟标准逐渐的完善起来
比如说业务对产品跟运营对产品都不是很了解
那么这个时候专业度就没有体现出来
那么运营把握一广产品的话就不够精准
这个时候就要进行产品做业的培训
第二种情况就是业务可能它的话术
或者是说它聊天的方式可能就存在问题
这种情况我们就需要去对一些话术培训啊
或者是说提升一些它的销售技巧啊
这些板块都是可以提升的
所以寻盘差不是单单运营的问题
它是整个公司可能涉及到店铺的定位是否够清晰
运营目标是否清晰
业务的聊天技巧是否有足够的支撑
那么这样其实它是一个完整的链路的
所以每一个环节你要去做好了
才能够获得更好的效果
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里
希望这个能够给你更多的一些新的思路和启发
去思考如何去优化和如何去与业务跟上下级去进行一个合作
这样我们的店铺产能会更好的发展
更好的发展
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们再见